this year a big piece of legislation
that we're supporting is called the
keeping girls in school at the keeping
girls in school act makes education for
adolescent girls a priority when it
comes to investing in international aid
this act would benefit girls all around
the world but it specifically calls on
the US government to prioritize areas
where girls are kept out of school it
would be addressing the fourteen biggest
barriers that hold girls back
so that's child marriage like you
mentioned it's hiv/aids and diseases
like that
it's gender-based violence its lack of
menstrual hygiene products and it's the
first time the US government has done
something like this so how can we
support for this act to be passed how
could how can global citizens do that so
we have a petition that's live on our
platform right now we would love you to
sign the petitions we're really trying
to amplify the numbers over the next few
weeks I think you know using your voice
and encouraging these leaders to really
step up would make a big difference we
know the one thing that will move the
needle is if members of Congress are
contacted by their constituents dear
members of Congress every girl deserves
to fulfill her potential but today over
a hundred million dollars and girls
globally are missing or leaving school
altogether barriers such as poor
sanitation child marriage and the based
violence and conflict are keeping girls
out of school and economies this must
change and keeping girls in school Act
will ensure US aid helps the most
vulnerable girls worldwide to stay in
school this
signature of that petition I agree we
need to get many many more people to
decide oh yes for sure giving the girls
the right to an education is as basic a
human right as men getting the right to
an education getting an education gives
them the ability to get a handle on
their futures
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]